un but qui suffit à leur bonheur les
trappistes sont assuré l'essentiel ce
dimanche 10 février en s'imposant 1 à 0
à domicile face à paris-xiii dans une
rencontre marquée par les incidents en
fin de partie des conditions climatiques
difficiles on a réussi à développer un
jeu assez porte d'aix au monde y passe
que les terrains ne permettait pas trop
mais ça a été le but il nous a vraiment
libérés du coup après on a essayé de
poser la balle pour jouer un match
engagé puisque radicale mais un bon
match dans l'ensemble on a su respecter
les consignes qui était donné une
victoire 1 0 qui me semble mérité cette
victoire était également importante sur
le plan comptable ce résultat permet à
trèbes de conserver son avance sur son
adversaire du jour
c'est assez serré au niveau des points
c'était un concurrent direct c'est avec
cette victoire et ben on aimait à cinq
points derrière nous du coup ça nous
soulage et savoureux tira concurrents
pour un pour meetic
à neuf journées de la fin du championnat
trap est toujours invaincu avec la
meilleure défense l'équipe pointe à la
deuxième place de régionale 3 on va
prendre les matches les uns après les
autres à la fin son dernier sprint y a
quelque chose à jouer à jouer band
jouera à fond à l'objectif et prend les
matchs après les autres et un président
je pense qu'en restant solide sera une
place intéressante en fin de saison
prochain match pour les trappistes ce
dimanche 17 février à domicile contre
franconville l'occasion d'étendre cette
série d'invincibilité à 14 matches